[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and how we can use it to solve
linear systems of equations ax equal to
B and now we're ready to talk about
building linear regression models from
data so this is really exciting because
regression models are one of the best
tools we have when we have measurement
data to build predictive models that we
can use for the future and in some sense
I mean linear regression is kind of the
first step in lots of lots of approaches
to learning it's the first model you
would try to build if you had data okay
so I'm gonna walk you through this and
we're gonna talk about how how you would
compute this and we're actually going to
run a couple of code examples on real
data to play around with these
regression models okay so the idea here
is that I might have some matrix a and
I'm gonna draw it as a tall skinny
matrix a times a vector X would equal
some output B so a x equals B and what I
do this in the over determined case
because oftentimes that's what we have
in modern data examples so I want to I
want to walk through like a very
concrete example of what what this
regression model might be let's say that
every row of this every row equation is
based on data from an individual humans
medical history okay so every every row
is an individual person okay this is
let's say this is my row and every
column of the a matrix our risk factors
like you might have age weight our us
smoker
etc etc okay age weight smoker diet so
on and so forth and maybe the B vector
is your risk of heart disease so this is
the risk of heart disease and what we
would like to do is from a large data
set where we actually follow maybe
10,000 people and we measure their their
risk factors and then we figure out
they actually get heart disease at some
point in the future so we actually have
data for a and for B we would want to
learn a best-fit model X for what
combination of those factors describe
best or predict best the future risk of
heart disease okay so for example in
this case you know you have your age
your weight I'm not a smoker etc etc I
multiply that vector by X which is my
model to some extent it's my model for
how those risk factors translate into a
probability or a risk of heart disease
okay I'm massively oversimplifying here
but this is the basic idea of what we
might want to do based on real
measurement data so I would actually
measure the a matrix and the B matrix
this might cost 50 million dollars to go
and do this
large large cardiac study to measure all
of these variables for ten thousand
people but once I had that I'd want to
build the best possible model X so that
in the future if I have a new patient I
all instead of having to compute their
risk of heart disease which might be
very complicated I don't want to wait to
see if they get it I just ask them a few
questions I multiply them by this X
vector and I get a number which is
hopefully predictive of their their
future risk of heart disease so that's
the idea and again this is something
where we're gonna want to solve we're
not going to be able to find an X that
exactly solves this model for every
single person because it's over
determined and noisy and messy but we
want to find the x that minimizes the
error norm between a X and B that gives
us the best prediction of B given
information in a okay so that's how
we're using least squares to solve these
regression models and I'm just gonna
draw some pictures here we're gonna code
this up on some real data so I'm not
going to be too precise here but let's
say that I have my axes a and B so B is
the thing I want to predict a is a
measurement that I get to use to predict
B and I'm just going to draw this in the
one dimensional case so let's say I have
a bunch of data that's scattered around
and it looks like this so if I asked you
does a predict be you would say it looks
pretty good it looks roughly linear
there's pretty low spread in this
direction and you could eyeball a
best-fit line like this where B equals a
times X okay
and the X here that we want is the slope
of this line so we're going to be
solving for that X for the slope of the
best fit line using linear regression
least squares regression in one
dimension okay now what's really nice
about this and I'm gonna walk you
through how to do this
all of this regression generalizes to
very high-dimensional very big data in
this matrix system of equations instead
of having one factor a that I'm using to
predict B I maybe I have a hundred
factors a that I'm going to use to
predict be none of the math changes okay
so in general I could have you know
factor one and I could have factor two
and factor three and four and five and I
could build this instead of a best fit
line I could find a best fit plane that
models B as a function of these input
factors the columns of my a matrix okay
now for now I'm going to keep it simple
and I'm just going to assume that I have
one factor a and I'm gonna try to
predict be using that one factor and
usually my data is gonna come in the
form of pairs of measurements a 4-person
one and B for person 1 a 4 person 2 and
B for person 2 and so on and so forth
and I'm gonna have a lot of these
measurements and I'm gonna stack them
into these tall vectors of data this is
actually the data I'm gonna get is like
let's say this is a 1 B 1 for person 1
and this is a 2 B 2 for a person 2 and
so on and so forth every person is a dot
on this on this the scatterplot and I'm
going to arrange them like this and then
I'm gonna try to find the best fit slope
X that map's a into B and what's nice is
that this is going to generalize
that if we have multiple factors you
know multi-vector of measurements for
person 1 person 2 person 3 we can find
the best fit slope X that models B okay
good and so in one dimensions this is
quite simple
essentially in in one dimension what we
have if I just compute the SVD of this a
matrix because that's how I'm going to
pseudo-inverse I'm gonna get u equals my
a vector divided by its norm a divided
by its norm I'm gonna have Sigma equals
just the norm of a and because this is a
one dimensional matrix it has just one
column the V matrix is going to be
trivial it's just going to be one so V
is going to equal one and it's really
easy to compute the pseudo inverse of
this to solve for X using this formula
here and I'm just going to write out
what the answer is the best fit X X
tilde that best fits this this slope of
this line is equal to a transpose B so
the inner product of my a vector and my
B vector divided by the norm of a
squared okay that is my best fit slope
and it kind of makes sense right what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
basically take B all of the B data and
project it into the direction of a
that's what this is and then I'm gonna
normalize that a vector by its length
and I'm gonna normalize the B vector by
its length because I'm gonna multiply
that slope by a to get B okay so this is
the best fit line it's exactly what you
would get if you plug these values into
this pseudo inverse in this formula here
but this formula generalizes to much
higher dimensional data where there are
multiple risk factors and you want to
build models so I think that's pretty
cool now the last thing I'm going to
point out is that in in data analysis
often you have outliers so this what
I've drawn there's some variability
maybe there's some
Gaussian noise on top of this this line
because every person has a little bit of
variability there's not a perfect model
for all people but if I have a massive
outlier down here someone just was
completely different than everyone else
what that's normally going to do is it's
going to completely bias my distribution
my best fit slope because it's trying to
minimize the sum of the squares of the
errors of all of these points to the
line and at this point is really far
away then the square of that distance is
much bigger than the square of all of
these distances and it's going to pull
the whole distribution down so this is
the risk we have when we have outliers
or corruption in the data and so
regularly squares based on the SVD can
handle white noise really really well ok
so if there's some Gaussian distributed
data you're gonna find the best slope
but if there are a few big outliers then
this is actually going to be very very
sensitive to those outliers and so this
is gonna motivate a lot of what we're
going to talk about in Chapter three of
our book on robust statistics compressed
sensing sparsity and there are robust
variants of this so we're gonna find
robust fits where we add an l1 penalty
term to kind of discount outliers
okay so we'll talk a lot about that in
Chapter three I just wanted to point out
now that that is a risk of these
outliers but if you have relatively
clean data or it only has kind of
Gaussian noise or Gaussian distribution
then this is actually going to be
optimal for forfeiting your data is this
singular value decomposition and this
all follows section 1.4 in the book
everything here and the next videos
we're gonna code up some examples of
this to show you how to actually fit
these things to show you what happens
when you have outliers or multiple
factors okay thank you